WAS NOT RELEASED.
WE HAVE THE PICTURE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WE JUST SHOWED THE PHOTOGRAPH OF
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
BEFORE HE WAS PRESIDENT WITH
FARRAKHAN.
YOU TOOK THE PICTURE.
WHERE WITH US IT?
>> IN THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK
CAUCUS MEETING ROOM.
THE BASEMENT OF THE CAPITAL
WHERE MEETINGS ARE HELD AND
THAT'S WHERE IT TOOK PLACE.
>> Tucker: WHY HAVE WE NEVER
SEEN THIS PICTURE BEFORE?
>> A COUPLE THINGS.
I WAS HONOR-BOUND.
A MEMBER FROM THE BLACK CAUCUS
SAID WE HAVE TO HAVE THE PICTURE
TO MINISTER FARRAKHAN AS
TO MINISTER FARRAKHAN A
TO MINISTER FARRAKHAN'S
TO MINISTER FARRAKHAN'S CHIEF OF
STAFF AND GAVE THE ORIGINAL DISK
TO HIM AND IN A SENSE SWORE
MYSELF TO SECRECY BECAUSE I MADE
A COPY FOR MY LIFE.
IT'S MY PICTURE, MY ART, MY
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
>> Tucker: BUT WHY WOULD THEY
NOT WANT THE PICTURE TO COME
OUT?
>> NOT SO MUCH THE NATION OF
ISLAM BUT PERHAPS THE BLACK
CAUCUS.
THIS WAS 2005, NOW.
HE'D JUST BEEN IN THE OFFICE A
FEW MONTHS.
THE IDEA -- AND IN FACT HE HAD
IN CHICAGO.
THE MEMBERS OF THE NATION OF
ISLAM HELPED HIM IN HIS SENATE
CAMPAIGN ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO.
I THINK AS PEOPLE CONSIDERED THE
AMBITIONS, THE THOUGHT WAS
MINISTER FARRAKHAN AND HIS
REPUTATION WOULD HURT SOMEONE
TRYING TO WIN ACCEPTANCE IN THE
BROAD CROSS SECTION.
>> Tucker: DID HE HAVE CONTACT
WITH ANYONE FROM THE NATION OF
ISLAM AS SENATOR THAT YOU KNOW
OF?
>> AS I RECALL THERE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE NATION OF ISLAM IN
CHICAGO WORKED ON HIS STAFF IN
HIS CONSTITUENT SERVICES OFFICE
BUT I NEVER KNEW HER NAME.
AT SOME POINT SHE WAS NO LONGER
ON HIS STAFF.
>> Tucker: WERE LOUIS FARRAKHAN
OR MEMBERS OF THE NATION OFFEND
PRESIDENT OBAMA WANTED TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF.
>> THEY WERE.
SOME WERE ANGRY AND SOME HURT.
NOT ONLY DID SENATOR OBAMA
DENOUNCE MINISTER FARRAKHAN BUT
REJECTED HIM.
IN THE SAME INTERVIEW APPEARING
WITH SENATOR CLINTON.
WHEN ASKED REJECTED THE SUPPORT
OF SOME PEOPLE SHE CONSIDERED IN
NEW YORK WHEN SHE WAS IN THE
SENATE AND DEMANDED HE DO THE
SAME.
HE SAID, OKAY.
I'LL REJECT HIM TOO.
SO PEOPLE IN THE NATION HAVE A
SENSITIVITY ABOUT THIS AND FEEL
WE'VE OFTEN BEEN MADE --
MINISTER FARRAKHAN HAS BEEN A
PEOPLE WHO WANT THE
BEING ASSOCIATED WITH MINISTER
FARRAKHAN.
>> Tucker: I WISH IT'D COME OUT
EARLIER BECAUSE IT MAKES FOR AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION.